this is the test this is also the first
episode I ever saw this show oh really
oh yeah that's right you're telling me
that I chose one we were at a convention
I don't know I think you were wandering
artists alley and I was up in the room
and it was on Cartoon Network I was
flipping through the channels I'm like
well let's see what this shows all about
because everyone was telling us that we
should V log in and yeah was this
episode in which ever one Cartoon
Network was running after this and I
came to you yeah I saw one that they ran
after it that you're talking about yeah
and I was just like I I think um I think
you need to watch this show yeah should
be welcome it was the one I saw before
this that I said I think you need to
watch so oh really all right well we'll
see what happens yeah well no no no the
what yeah the one that the whatever
though the what were you saw was way
more recent I think no no the one that
was before this the fusion one I was a
fusion yeah okay I was like I feel you
really need to see fish so we both knew
it like we had no problem do we do I did
I knew nothing about this show going
into this episode I was just like okay I
guess I'll pieces together I'm like
they're called gems must have super
powers Stephen has three mommies I know
um and I liked all the video game
references the video game soundtrack
yeah this one probably was about
building up his confidence I there was
somebody in the Rose I didn't know who
Rose was at the time and I mentioned her
at the end so I was like yeah this is a
really solid episode it's funny because
it makes more sense now but I kind of
figured out most of it just getting
dumpster yeah that is well that you know
watching and I'm always can't thing my
civil kids figure this out can they
follow this whatever but kind of like
what you said I'm thinking about shows
we watched it's like we usually figured
it out they did have this long
explaining together like if I kept
watching episodes after this I'm sure
would have figure out who all these
people were but yeah um I do have the
the video game levels they design um
it's kinda like Marble Madness animal
cell Mario Brothers yeah I like same I
remember Marble Madness the game was
fucking awesome yeah it's very short it
while depending on how good you are
but um yeah I know her my world
everything you know is wrong yes you
have to go upward step downward so who
blew your mind I have to go backwards go
forwards come on go get come
um but yeah it was uh I really liked
those video game levels I liked it was
nothing like 100% direct from anything
it just has that feeling the fun a
little theme when he completes every
single one I really love that that
little musical double anything is yeah I
went and I was like wow this really is
like a video game they look anyway they
like with the little star balloons and I
won't fucking play this game yeah I need
to make a video game based on this you
probably eat it very quickly but I you
would make it I hired her um but what I
what I like about this episode is that
you know the whole thing is that gems
want to make Steven feel like you know
that he's evolving it they want him to
genuinely evolve but they also don't
want him to hurt himself and rightfully
so if these were real he would be a
million pieces by now he's whooping
squash he would have made it through up
until the spikes and yeah you know be
dead so you can't blame him but it's
also this idea that they're they're
trying to do it cuz they know he really
needs them uh to build the confidence
and stuff and what I like about this
episode is at the very end you realize
like how much they really need as well
ya know and they really need him to
build their confidence that they're
doing a good job um I think I hope you
forget that uh with like Parenthood I
think that's what guarded what they've
done to each they were pretty much
saying it's like we have no clue what
the hell we're doing yeah that they felt
rows rows would've but where's my god
that that was a line of the Casper movie
I really love is when the father said
he's talking to the mother the dead
mother says I have no idea what I'm
doing it she says what parent does and
that's it that's very true I mean this
show really can't compare to Casper but
well I thought the Magisters Casper but
know it is something that I think is
very true that you know a lot to eat
just wing it and you do your best and
that the two it isn't the parents
probably do give more you know obviously
to the child they had to raise a child
but the child really does give a lot to
the parents that you know where the
child or the parents realize it but you
know they do feed into each other unless
it's like children of the corn
the bad seed or something yeah man
that's that's very fucked up um but yeah
yeah I can't think of much else to say
about this there's a-- i like when he
goes to sort of the top of a levels of
just column uh and he's walking through
and he sees how they work and it's very
quiet i can't explain it but there's
something it's an even in a game you
sort of find that secret level or you go
like a level beyond it's like somewhere
that's like you i don't know somehow you
find it and it's a quiet level you sir
feel like who this is like it's like all
the other levels and like sounds and big
stuff and this is just a quiet level and
it there's something that's almost like
magical about your behind-the-scenes
do do it like i can't explain it but it
is somehow it kind of capture that
whether it was intentional or not um but
yeah there's something or like we see
behind the scenes of like anything like
an amusement park or something like that
and there's like it's not like wow look
at that or isn't that cool or anything
it's like you like really quiet and
really subdued and there's something
really realize that all the screws are
coming loose yeah well I do um but uh
yeah I'm trying to think what else I
guess not really much it's interesting
that that thing that episode was a test
you know uh the whole time uh but yeah I
mean I thought was good I think the
ending is kind of what makes it the most
um I think you just went oh no I just
had tears down the krantz where I just
like oh but ya know it was a it was not
only cute it was meaningful it was a you
know very meaningful episode I think you
know shows the strength on a
relationship between all of them so um
ya think that's about it and we will see
it the next one see you there